here's the Wall Street Journal this
weekend just in U.S energy department
has concluded that the covid pandemic
most likely arose from a laboratory leak
according to a new classified
intelligence report why is it this is
the question why is it that the machine
was so hell-bent on none of us thinking
that it might be a lab leak perhaps then
it would it would be because then we'd
really have to think about what our
relationship with China is right and was
this a bio weapon and was this
intentional and did the NIH found
actually fund some of this stuff which
fauci under oath said that we did not
but we've got quite a segue for you uh
here is fauci contradicting news reports
that gain of function was happening at
the Wuhan lab funded by the NIH we I I
don't know how many times I can say it
Madam chair we did not fund gain of
function research to be conducted in the
Wuhan Institute suit of virology
in our health lead we now know that a
bat coronavirus was enhanced in a lab
NIH an Nia D categorically has not
funded gain of function research to be
conducted in the Wuhan Institute the
National Institutes of Health
acknowledged that it funded research of
a virus that was studied at the Wuhan
Institute of virology the experiment
unexpectedly we're told made a bad
coronavirus more contagious than the
original naturally occurring one Dr
fauci knowing that it is a crime to lie
to Congress do you wish to retract your
statement of May 11th where you claimed
that the NIH never funded gain of
function research in Wuhan
senator Paul I have never lied before
the Congress and I do not retract that
statement a new letter raising questions
about experiments in a Wuhan lab what
was let me finish take an animal virus
and you increase his responsibility to
humans right you're saying that's not
getting a function yeah that is correct
and and senator Paul you do not know
what you are talking about quite frankly
and I want to say that officially you do
not know what you are talking about
three years the National Institutes of
Health provided grant money to the Eco
Health Alliance research Group which
conducted experiments with bad
coronaviruses on China okay so you
really got to understand what fauci is
doing here he's been caught everyone
gets it he's playing and I think this is
what he was doing under oath he's
playing some weird game whether the
nih-funded Eco health or how the money
got around or whether it was a mistake
or not and that's what his lawyers you
know once this really bubbles up further
as the truth is that time release bill
and more and more people look into this
and go man he really he did lie on the
road because NIH did fund gain of
function research they were looking into
this coronavirus and then they gain a
function you added a function to it you
add a function to a virus to make it
jump to human so it can either be used
as a bioweapon or so that pharmaceutical
companies can come in and be like oh my
God there's this crazy virus out there
we don't know where it came from but
you're not going to believe this we have
a vaccine for this thing and it's just
been sitting in the chest over there
it's wild we had it in the basement on
ice
[Music]
foreign